Dustin Diamond - the actor best known for
portraying Samuel "Screech" Powers, the resident
geek of his friend group, on Saved by the
Bell - has died.
Roger Paul, Diamond's representative, confirmed
the tragic news to The Hollywood Reporter
on Monday, February 1st, 2021.
TMZ also reports that a representative for
Diamond, likely Paul but unnamed in the outlet's
coverage, verified that Diamond died on Monday
morning, with his girlfriend at his side.
He was 44 years old.
In January 2021, it was announced via a statement
posted to Diamond's official Facebook page
that the actor had been diagnosed with lung
cancer.
An update posted on January 22nd, 2021 confirmed
that Diamond's diagnosis was "stage 4 small
cell carcinoma," and that he was "being treated
and fighting this."
As of mid-January, Diamond was undergoing
chemotherapy, and his representative noted
at the time that after a week of treatments,
the people around Diamond hoped to "have a
much better understanding of the severity
of his condition and what treatments he will
need so that he's comfortable."
Paul issued a press release, shared with Looper,
during the afternoon of February 1st.
In it, he confirmed that Diamond "did not
suffer" in the time leading up to his death.
Paul wrote,
"He was diagnosed with this brutal, relentless
form of malignant cancer only three weeks
ago.
In that time, it managed to spread rapidly
throughout his system; the only mercy it exhibited
was its sharp and swift execution.
Dustin did not suffer.
He did not have to lie submerged in pain.
For that, we are grateful.
Dustin Diamond was a character in and of himself:
an unpredictable spitfire who always left
us shocked, but never left us bored.
We are thankful he trusted us enough to share
his genuine, authentic self with our team.
We wish you knew him in the way that we did.
We please ask that you give room for privacy
to our team and Mr. Diamond's family during
this tragic time, as we grieve and remember
the memories spent together.
This loss is as much stinging as it is sudden."
Though Diamond began his acting career a few
years before Saved by the Bell, with credits
in projects like American Playhouse and Purple
People Eater, his sitcom character Screech
was the one that made him a household name
and an icon of pop culture from the late '80s
through to the new millennium.
Diamond first brought Screech to life in the
1988 Disney Channel series Good Morning, Miss
Bliss, which centered around a teacher named
Carrie Bliss and the eighth-grade students
she taught at a junior high in Indiana.
The show, later known as Saved by the Bell:
The Junior High Years, also starred two other
Saved by the Bell mainstays, Mark-Paul Gosselaar's
Zack Morris and Lark Voorhies' Lisa Turtle.
In 1989, Powers, Morris, and Turtle began
appearing as series regulars on Saved by the
Bell, alongside the other core characters:
Tiffani Thiessen's Kelly Kapowski, Mario Lopez's
A.C. Slater, and Elizabeth Berkley's Jessie
Spano.
The NBC series, about a group of students
navigating the high school hierarchy and occasionally
confronting some more serious troubles, ran
until 1993, but two spin-offs followed not
long after: Saved by the Bell: The College
Years and Saved by the Bell: The New Class.
Diamond starred in both - as well as the two
Saved by the Bell movies that aired in 1992
and 1994, respectively, Saved by the Bell
Hawaiian Style and Saved by the Bell Wedding
in Las Vegas.
The years that marked Diamond's post-Saved
by the Bell career were filled with ups and
downs - underscored with the release of the
controversial tell-all book Behind the Bell,
his involvement in a Saved by the Bell-themed
adult film, his various legal troubles, and
his appearances on shows like Celebrity Fit
Club and Celebrity Big Brother.
In November 2020, NBCUniversal's streaming
service Peacock rolled out the Saved by the
Bell reboot series - of which Diamond was
not a part.
Diamond was disappointed to have not been
included in the revival, especially considering
his fellow cast mates were folded into the
fresh show in one way or another, but showrunner
Tracey Wigfield said that there would be a
possibility for the actor to be included in
a second season, should he be interested.
Sadly, that's now no longer a possibility,
and Diamond's final performance as Screech
will now forever remain in the "Breaking Belding"
digital short.
Our thoughts are with Diamond's loved ones
during this time of grief.